from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between mcdonald's and india in the u.s
this is food wars
drinks in mcdonald's india come in three
sizes regular medium and large drinks to
the mcdonald's in the u.s four sizes
extra small small medium and large
time to keep them honest
lost a couple drops 26 27 fluid ounces
fries in india come in three sizes
regular medium and large in america our
fries come in four sizes i think
we have a
small
kids
or
kids small i can't tell the difference
either
medium
and large the medium and large come in
this really cool new packaging where you
can just
open it up like that and it's nice and
easy to share it's a little plate good
job mcdonald's very innovative but now
it's time to measure and see how much
we're really getting first things first
the large
175 grams obviously it's different per
scoops or whatever yeah let's go ahead
this one
almost exactly 100 grams
this one
80 grams fry math hang on
this is like
yep there you go 20 that's 20 gram
difference right there so you tell me
internet is the kids in the small
different sizes i don't think they are
food wars is on it right baby what about
mcnuggets here in india you can order
them in three sizes
six pieces
nine pieces and twenty pieces they give
it to us in two boxes of ten each oh is
that it india cute our mcnuggets start
at four
then you got six
ten
twenty
and not to be outdone booyah forty
mcnuggets all the math heads watching
we'll be quick to point out that that is
double india's largest nugget option the
only burger that india shares with the
us is the mcchicken the humble mcchicken
not even gonna bother with the analog
scale now
boop
149 grams ah it's so frustrating just
one more gram and it'll be perfect
with the paper i mean
we'll do this and
shave off
an eighth of an ounce our mcchicken
weighs
140 grams
[Music]
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at mcdonald's india that you will
not find in the usa and here's all the
mcdonald's menu items from the u.s you
won't find in india here in india we
can't really recreate the iconic
mcdonald's big mac because it's made
from a beef patty and to keep to the
religious sentiments of hindus and even
muslims we don't serve beef or pork in a
lot of fast food restaurants we have
something called the chicken
maharaja mac as you can see it's got
three buns two patties a lot of cheese
and mayonnaise some tomatoes onions
lettuce let us try it now
[Music]
oh my god
that is truly a maharaja mac
if you're wondering a raja is a king and
a maharaja is like an emperor so this is
clearly our answer to the big mac now
let's say it's the veg maharaja mac i
think it's actually a very cool
challenge that a lot of fast food
restaurants here have had to adapt to
the indian palette as well as
sensibilities of food we have come up
with such cool
iconic fast food that you won't get
anywhere else in the world like look at
this this is outrageous there's no way
to eat this without being messy this
literally wrote away
mmm oh my god that's really good yes to
all that
looks really good because of india's
lack of beef all the american beef
options are technical exclusives
all right
big mac there it is
just
brimming with stuff
my go-to for like 20 years i still get
it occasionally the classic
mcdonald's hamburger beef patty ketchup
and mustard of course
and get it with cheese hi
you can upgrade to a double cheeseburger
or a mcdovell what's the difference you
ask
i'm not sure either so let's start with
the double cheeseburger look at that
look how yellow that is beef cheese beef
cheese tacos the mcdouble is beef
cheese
beef so it's just one slice of cheese in
the middle but not on top what's the
price difference can we get that on
screen
and how much is a slice of cheese
joe's hack get yourself a mcdouble and
bring your own slice of american cheese
booyah save yourself this amount of
money the problem with millennials today
the reason you guys can't buy houses is
you're spending all your money at
starbucks you're getting your double
cheeseburgers instead of a mcdouble and
bringing your own cheese slice i mean
you guys are terrible with money what
are you eating what seven eight
mcdoubles a day like me right that adds
up to like at the end of the year
18
10 000 years later that's a down payment
on a house
wait
what are you guys doing all right next
up is the iconic mikalu tikki burger you
take mashed potato and you fry it in
breadcrumbs and you get this really
delicious cutlet here in india they
adapted it into this
burger with a very special sauce some
tomato and chopped onions
it's just so classic they nailed this
burger next up there is a mexican mekalu
tikki which i assume has
stereotypical mexican ingredients and
flavors like jalapeno yes jalapeno
nice it's way more spicy good twist
next up they have a mech egg burger make
egg
make egg make egg i don't know why i did
that let's see what that looks like oh
sorry i did not expect pesto
next up is a chicken kebab burger every
time an indian fast food chain tries to
adapt an indian special
food into a burger i take it with a
pinch of salt because this is not what
we're used to seeing when we think of
kebabs but i'm gonna try it and let's
see what happens
very very dry
patty has almost like a cardboardy taste
to it i wouldn't put those flavors
together if i was thinking kebab
make cardboard tikki maybe no okay
that's a bit harsh i'm sorry next up is
the mech veggie which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our mcchicken
if i had to eat this versus the chicken
one i would not be upset at all
really good next up we have two american
burgers the american cheese supreme
wedge
and the american cheese supreme
chicken
my hunch for what makes them american is
that they will have a nice big square of
cheese and they will not be spicy at all
except they have a lot of jalapenos on
them joe let me know if this constitutes
american
that's american cheese my man that's
what makes it american i don't know
about those other toppings but yeah that
sounds about right all right so this is
what the mcdonald's website says is in
this burger whole wheat bun source from
maharashtra tangy jalapenos from
karnataka
shredded onions grown in local indian
farms
and cheese from amaravati
also
in india quite quite close to home this
burger currently this would probably be
my favorite order a mixed spicy chicken
and there's the vegetarian option which
is a mix spicy paneer which is just
leaking lettuce for those of you who
don't know what paneer is it's basically
cottage cheese we love our paneer we put
in curries we eat it plain we put it in
kebabs it is so delicious let's try this
has just the right kick and it goes
really well with the paneer fair warning
while this may have a light kick of
spice for us it might be a hard kick for
you so
take everything with a pinch of chili
powder gonna move up to something called
the quarter pounder and that's like
their big burger so you can get a
quarter pound of cheese here it is i
mean this looks it looks fake right like
just kidding it's cake or the the new
one is uh it's actually a candle
and then you can get quarter pounder
with cheese deluxe more veggies on it
all the junk that i brush off you can
upgrade to a double quarter partner with
cheese let's take a look oh man look how
thick this is
and then you can get that same double
with bacon yeah oh man skimping on the
bacon guys
what we lack in beef burgers we make up
for in gourmet burgers that's right here
in mcdonald's india we have our own
collection of chef special gourmet
burgers
delicious and i think this is a rolling
menu i think they introduce new things
from time to time the buns themselves
look a lot more
gourmet you know there's a nice riff
down the middle kind of looks like a
butt uh but that's okay we're not gonna
concentrate on that
first up we have triple cheese american
veg burger and triple cheese american
chicken burger same thing cheese
jalapeno some sauce lettuce simple
chicken patty a gourmet bun
does this scream american to you next up
cheese lava american vege burger and
cheese lava american chicken burger
again with american and again with the
with a strange relation of food to
volcanoes and lava
okay
this burger is very spicy
this qualifies as a volcano product for
sure congratulations mcdonald's the lava
in the title of this burger works
the mex spicy chicken premium though
has an egg patty inside of it
that's pretty good
i just feel so existential right now
imagine sitting here at this table and
just tasting every single burger in
mcdonald's menu
amazing
but also
we also have some exclusive wrap options
we have big spicy paneer and big spicy
chicken i think this is the same mex
spicy chicken patty and it's wrapped
around a tortilla which is actually way
closer to an indian chapati than most
other fast food restaurants it doesn't
feel as
synthetic our mcdonald's in the us had
wraps for a brief period of time one day
they were gone
nobody noticed yeah you guys got some
chicken stuff that we don't have but we
got a few of our own more recently than
you think they finally introduced their
chicken sandwich to an already crowded
chicken sandwich market and that is of
course their crispy chicken sandwich and
this thing is fantastic it's one of the
best ones they relate to the game and
they kind of took it over in my opinion
i like about it it's simple look at this
you just got crispy chicken pickles that
suck it's baller it tastes great like a
little spicy india
it probably doesn't compare to you guys
a rocket in india but you know this one
has a little nice heat to it
pickles sauce wanna take it up a notch
gotta go deluxe
the cool crispness of the vegetables
just clash so well
with the spicy sauce it's good it's good
nikhil say the word and i'm putting one
in the post for you tomorrow so when it
arrives in three weeks you can throw it
out
now we're getting into exclusive side
dishes here in india we have these
add-ons number one
the veg
pizza mcpuff this is one of the most
delicious things we have here it's
basically a pizza hot pocket masala
veggies these are potato veggies with
classic indian masala flavor to them oh
boy masalas are basically what we use to
spice and flavor dishes and they consist
primarily of ground up spices like
cardamom cloves red chillies kashmiri
chilies you go to every indian home the
mums the grandmoms will have their own
random you know masala mix that they use
and that's guarded and treasured in
their family forever next up we have
cheesy masala veggies they're also
serving a classic cup of boiled corn
which is so unique and they give you a
side of amul butter
guys amul butter is part of our culture
makhan
makhan
this is probably going to be the most
delicious bite of the day
i love corn
next up chicken strips they come in
packs of two
three or five cheesy
nugget veg bites yeah this is just a
vegetarian version of the chicken
nuggets and it's got some corn some
tomato
it's okay
next we have the double cheese mcmuffin
and lastly we have mexican cheesy fries
on the mcdonald's india website one
british customer said that these mexican
cheesy fries are the real deal
i have no idea how a british person can
say that mexican cheesy fries is the
real deal but anytime a british person
says that another culture is food is the
real deal it puts a little fear in our
small indian hearts yeah surprises like
ass and the next exclusive side that we
have is apple
slices cut them up
put them in a plastic bag about to get
saucy that's right ladies and gentlemen
sauce talk
thank you
honey mustard
tastes like salad dressing sour
i would tie it with the tiny barbecue
because it's so different so we'll keep
these guys
sent here
ranch i don't know america we love our
ranch that's just okay that's why i said
it ranch is just okay oh
and all ranch tastes the same
yeah
and finally honey
i like that
honey's the best one and all that money
all that energy all that time creating
all these recipes trying to sway the
american pop
the american mind and you got you got
beat by a bunch of bees
power to the bees
we have one exclusive spice mix as well
as one exclusive sauce here in india we
have chili sauce which is pretty
straightforward it's chili sauce but let
me tell you about piri piri spice
mix so mcdonald's launched this in 2013
here in india and it was so popular
there were riots when they said they
were going to discontinue it and so now
it's a permanent addition to the menu
first you get this shake bag then you
grab your fries and then you just pour
that in there ah
boom
oh boy
can we cut to a before of the fries and
you saw how they were now look at these
you can see the little flecks of spice
just adorning each fry
[Music]
hello it's christelle and i know nikhil
has perry perry mcdonald's chips but in
the uk it is all about nando's cheeky
nandos let's talk about perry perry
perry means pepper and it's a blend of
spices so it's got things like paprika
ground bird's eye chili a bit of oregano
a pinch of ginger and cardamom but it's
a portuguese spice blend it's funny
because obviously nikhil mentioned that
the peri-peri fries just blew off in
india and it makes sense because i'm
from goa which is in the south of india
goa was colonised by the portuguese and
so i really think that indians are
accustomed to that portuguese taste
palette which is why peri-peri fries are
doing so well in india but after talking
i want to dig into these fries because
they look great
that was just so good harry get involved
not eating chips without me no sorry
everybody had a head start
cheers
god damn if that isn't
like crack
for the early risers there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items at the u.s
mcdonald's sausage biscuit with egg next
one
sausage biscuit i mean they take the egg
out so it's just
this of course is bacon egg and cheese
ladies and gentlemen we've reached the
point of the breakfast where we get into
the mcgriddles i love mcgriddles what's
a mcriddle you ask india fantastic
question mcdonald's had this genius idea
to replace the breakfast sandwiches they
already had with pancakes
and they also like inject
syrup into it somehow but it is a
breakfast sandwich with pancakes for
buns and it's the best idea anyone's
ever had anywhere ever
look at this look at this look at this
there's like a little m in there this
mini pancake i know i'm running the
gloves but this was mine
we have a veg mcmuffin and a sausage
mcmuffin
the sausage here in india is not made
out of pork like it is in the u.s
instead it's made out of simple chicken
speaking of sausage
you can get breakfast burrito
bro i could put five of these away using
easy you're like a total drag
and you want oatmeal in the morning we
have it it's about as inspiring as you
would think
hot cakes and sausage of course it comes
with hot syrup this here
the big breakfast with hot cakes and
it's big a lot of eggs
kind of wimpy looking bacon
got yourself two english muffins here
and of course it comes with hash brown
potatoes who doesn't love them
mcdonald's hash brown
undefeated these things are so good
india exclusive desserts we have a black
forest mcflurry a vanilla chocolate
muffin and a chocolate chip muffin it's
kind of like
a mcflurry soup right now
this would be really good when it was
actually a mcflurry desserts usa we got
them to start down here very simple choc
chip cookies
uh this next thing apple fritter right
this right here is called the glaze pull
apart donut
blueberry muffin if you had one you've
had them all this is a what type of
is creamy pie let's see what's inside
okay i'm suddenly more interested yeah
guava and cream
how about we'll call it the cream and
guava pie
now this sucks
i'll flip standard menu item to
mcdonald's apple pie everyone knows
about this i don't want a pizza version
of this
and last but not least cinnamon roll too
sticky i don't feel like eating it
update it's not sticky it's actually
exclusive drinks starting with we have
something called
b naturals mixed fruit juice
next up we have something that they call
raw mango fruit splash
oh
it's a bit too sweet berry lemonade
splash all of these come in these
very
unique reusable bottles apparently next
up strawberry chiller
green apple chiller and
lemon chiller
it's just flavored water that's exactly
what it is it's flavored water and i
kind of like it this is a mixed berry
smoothie
it's still quite sweet but quite good
next up american mud pie shake
that's pretty um drink roulette ooh and
the ice melted fantastic
dr pepper let's go
coke not exclusive
let's go sweet tea too sweet
oh yeah unsweetened tea not sweet enough
you guys combined for the kids watching
why are you watching where are your
parents or supervisors you can get
yourself apple juice
milk come on drinking milk the thought
of drinking straight milk like hurts my
stomach there's also chocolate milk on
the menu once upon a time this was an
iced french vanilla latte now it's more
of a room temperature french vanilla
latte
that's just okay it's like really like
really sweet strawberry banana smoothie
yeah i always love getting these these
are good so i'm gonna assume they're not
good for me exclusive hot drinks first
off we have strawberry green tea next up
uh english breakfast tea
and
moroccan tea next up a flat white coffee
india a land where we run on chai and
mcdonald's does not have a chai option
caramel macchiato
cappuccino
caramel latte a vanilla cappuccino the
vinegar with the v does look like a you
mcdonald's premium roast coffee
i'm gonna hang onto this one
in india a chicken maharajamak will cost
you 231 rupees for just the sandwich
that's around 3.03 us dollars we do not
have the chicken maharaja mac but we do
have the big mac and a big mac in the us
cost 4.89
that is a 61
price increase now what if you turn this
into a meal a mex saver maharajamak
combo comes with regular fries and a
regular drink and will cost you 356
rupees that is 4.67 us dollars still
less than the price of the american
sandwich on its own but does the combo
meal make a difference in the us a
medium big mac combo so big mac medium
fries medium drank it's 8.99
that's a 92
cost increase even worse than if you
just bought the sandwich on its own on
the indian mcdonald's menu you will find
a two-person meal which contains a
chicken maraja mak a veg maharaja mac
large fries two pizza mc puffs and
a drink all of this will cost you 681
rupees or 8.93 us dollars so basically
you're getting food for two people for
the price of one person's meal in the
u.s however while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the u.s it's still very
expensive and aspirational to people
over here your minimum wage per hour is
equal to our daily minimum wage and so
yeah a lot of people can't really afford
this kind of food the english-speaking
indians that you see in a lot of youtube
videos on the internet aren't really a
proper reflection of the majority of
people that live in this country who
still can't afford food like this so
i'm checking my privilege and we should
all make sure we check ours but let's
play devil's advocate mcdonald's india
has definitely included a lot more
affordable options on their menu and so
they are more approachable to the
average urban indian than other fast
food chains
[Music]
let's compare some items to see who has
the least healthy mcdonald's food in the
u.s a mcchicken contains
400 calories 21 grams of fat 39 grams of
carbs five of those are sugar and 560
milligrams of sodium how about the
indian mcchicken one of these contains
398 calories 15 grams of total fat 48
grams of carbs 5 grams of which are
sugars
787 milligrams of sodium so the indian
version has slightly fewer calories way
lesser fats but much more carbs and
sodium
what if we made that a combo meal well a
medium fry in the u.s contains the
following
320 calories 15 grams of total fat 43
grams of carbs no sugar and 260
milligrams of sodium while a medium
price in india contains 340 calories 17
grams of total fat 41 grams of carbs 0
grams of sugars and 256 milligrams of
sodium and if we add the medium coke
that is adding 210 calories no fat 56
grams of carbs 56 of those are sugar and
55 milligrams of sodium oh a nice salty
coke we'll do the same here in india one
medium coke will cost you 151 calories 0
grams of fat 38 grams of carbs 38 grams
of which are sugars
and there are zero grams of sodium but
my god that is a lot of sugar packed in
this cup that leaves the indian meal at
a grand total of 889 calories 32 grams
of fat 127 grams of carbs out of which
43 grams of sugars and
1043 milligrams of sodium
which means this whole bad boy all
together is 930 calories 36 grams of
total fat 138 grams of carbs 61 of those
grams of sugar
875 milligrams of sodium a little bit
lower sodium than india but we got you
guys beat in calorie fats carbs and
sugar
we win we win
unfortunately for india the combo stats
are little misleading and the difference
maker is the coke because the american
meal has a larger portion if you order
the coke zero in both countries the
indian meal will actually have a higher
calorie count
mcdonald's india does not share a full
list of their ingredients but there are
some things we do know about their food
like did you know that mcdonald's india
actually changed indian farming
practices just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted when
they first launched in india in 1996
mcdonald's promised the government that
they would use products grown and
sourced right here in india but people
who had eaten mcdonald's abroad realized
that the fries didn't taste quite the
same the reason for this is that indian
potatoes were too small round had way
too much moisture and sugar content and
so the fries made out of them were not
long enough they didn't get crispy
enough and they didn't have that
distinctive mcdonald's
to them so mcdonald's partnered with
mccain foods and they spent nine years
trying to perfect their potato they
imported saplings which had the perfect
shape and starch content that they
needed they also chose gujarat as their
farming location for its climate and
they switched from a flood irrigation to
a sprinkler system to reduce moisture
content and save water
the result
bigger and more starchy potatoes that
can be used to make the mcdonald's fries
that you know and love mcdonald's in the
u.s mostly uses russet burbank or
shepadi chapati potatoes potato meat
so these are big enough for the
distinctive long fry yeah look how long
this is wow known to be low moisture and
low sugar content this means they can
remain crispy when fried and don't
caramelize too fast so you can get a
nice even brownie mcdonald's in the u.s
actually discloses all of its
ingredients so we can figure out a few
other differences in the us for instance
our mayonnaise contains egg yolk as does
most american male thanks to the faq
page on the mcdonald's india website we
found out that the mayonnaise is eggless
along with all of the other sauces
except for the tartar sauce when people
describe things as vegetarian here in
india they typically mean it doesn't
contain egg
did we quietly retire ronald and the
crew if we did thank god it's very
bizarre the whole ronald mcdonald thing
it's kind of nightmarish so
away he goes